the holidays are here and while you're
out busy shopping for presents leave the
cleaning to our next sponsors zerorez
ben mckee from xero res las vegas joins
us with just how easy it is to clean
your carpets it's good to see you guys
hey good to see you jc you brought a big
special your cyber week special what is
it we have right now you can get 20 off
20 off any regular price service and
we're gonna throw in two passes to the
festival of lanterns over at cowabunga
bay this is big there's not a better
time to book than right now this is huge
and the holidays this is a busy time of
year you got family coming over you want
clean carpets tell everyone about the
zero res difference you know ours well
first off it's holiday season you don't
want to have to worry about doing the
work yourself call zero res let us do
the heavy lifting
our technology is gonna out clean any
carpet cleaner or at home machine that
you have we can clean without soaps or
surfactants this leaves your carpet soft
to the touch
and just imagine decorating your house
with clean floors and clean carpets we
just put up our christmas tree over the
weekend my wife said to me we need to
get zero res out here because you guys
do my house and you do an amazing job i
got white carpets they come out crystal
clean when you guys are done i'm not the
only one singing your praises though
customer service is is one of the top
things you guys do it is we make sure
like we teach our guys every day guys
and gals to just make sure that we
provide the best customer experience to
the people that we serve and our our
ratings show that we have a 4.9 star
rating on google with over 6 000 reviews
today we've been voted best of las vegas
uh twice now
uh i mean the list goes on and on we
have accolades from industry
professionals we're platinum rated with
the carpet and rug institute if you're a
carpet nerd at home you might know who
that is that's big uh but it's we do
something right it's because we're not
cleaning with the soaps and surfactants
we're treating our customers like their
family and it just makes for an awesome
match all right let's do it this look at
this look at this rug right here can we
all see this rug so i hold it up so you
can see it better this is filth right
here this is dirty dirty dirty and we're
gonna get it clean right now what are we
doing that's right
so this is just our truck mount is
outside imagine having a 300 horsepower
vacuum coupled with our zr water
technology wow without any effort our
water can out clean soap surfactants
there's no toxic residue left behind and
your carpets stay cleaner longer look at
this unbelievable look at this this is
spectacular this is brand new carpet
right here because truly your carpet is
the biggest air filter in your house it
is and although vacuuming and regular
maintenance is really important
there's no replacement for carpet
cleaning especially with zero rest
carpet cleaning the thing if you've got
dogs and kids and the pet dander and
everything that goes in there you guys
are sucking it up it is great for
allergies it is in fact we've been
laboratory tested we remove up to 200
percent more soil and dander like you
said than any leading competitor out
there with our our cleaning technology
that we have so
and you know it we were also like pet
treatment experts out there
you just put my dogs on blast that's
what you guys did you put my dog but
it's true i have a pet accident you guys
come out and you clean it up immediately
the carpet dries so fast what's great
though come out clean the carpets the
carpets are drying your customers can go
to the festival of lanterns that's right
go have some fun out there so and you
also you do more than just carpets too
you do couches cow upholstery uh we do
air ducts we even do commercial air
ducts and that's the best part is all
our cleaning technology we can do at
your home or at your business
we clean tile and grout wood floors we
got you covered you do it all we just
saw some of the video there the festival
of lanterns out there the kids and
family having fun and you guys are
fantastic awesome we appreciate it clean
carpets you need it for the holiday
season give zero res a call at
vegas.com for 702-840-3333 cyber week
special 20 off all regular price uh
regular price services plus get two free
tickets to the festival of lanterns at
cowabunga bay
jillian we'll send it over to you